what if you could simplify how you use a
quantum computer so you can concentrate
on the higher level applications that
you actually care about
in this video we're going to be talking
about Quantum Primitives which will
hopefully help you accomplish this
earlier videos we looked at how to
program a quantum computer the basic
building block for this is a Quantum
circuit which looks something like this
the quantum circuit
is basically at the same level as
Assembly Language for a classical
computer in fact the open Chasm language
is just that it is an assembly language
that lets you write a Quantum circuit in
code
similarly when you run your Quantum
program
on a quantum computer
you get a low level result out
something that looks like this
one key area that makes Quantum
Computing different than classical
Computing is that it's probabilistic or
when you have a fixed input you can get
different outputs so we run the Circ
circuit or program multiple times and
the output is the number of times you
got each result
however when you're writing higher level
applications this is too level to
typically work with and you want to deal
with higher level constructs
such as probability distributions or
expectation values which are estimates
of observables
this is where Quantum Primitives come
into play
Quantum primitive
is basically
just a black box abstraction where you
give it your Quantum circuit input
and you get the output at the higher
level that you actually care about
inside the primitive
all the details on how you compute this
higher level output and all of the pre
and post processing that are necessary
to compute it are abstract it away from
you you previously and still can do this
manually if you so desire but the
Primitive greatly simplifies how you do
this
then vendors
of quantum computers like IBM provide
implementations of these Primitives
which
provide the most efficient software and
Hardware techniques to leverage the
Primitive to get the result the best
result that you want
if you're writing a higher level
application
where you have
a classical Optimizer that works with
these higher level results
this greatly simplifies how you write
the application because you don't have
to worry about the intermediate
computation you just have to deal with
how you build this higher level
application
hopefully this shows you how you can use
quantum Primitives to accelerate
developing higher level applications
there are more details and links for
this in the description below please
don't forget to like And subscribe and
if you have any questions please leave a
comment below thank you